away we go rapper kalis all smiles on a
European getaway amid rumors of her
unlikely romance with Bill Murray never
mind the pair's almost 30-year age gaps
[Music]
the singer shared a look at her grease
vacay on Instagram soaking up the Sun
and getting family time in with two of
her kids did that go
who's not seen the 73 year old comedian
but just a week ago the internet went
wild after this photo hit the gram
posted by Children of Zeus A hip-hop
group from England and the UK is where
Murray and Kelis are fueling dating
rumors et's reached out to both of their
reps for comments let's just leave it
right there meanwhile British tabloid
the sun says the two have been getting
close for a while with both recently
being spotted together at the same hotel
in London where he's currently filming
the next Ghostbusters sequel we could
have been the most spectacular power
couple
the movie's director Jason Reitman
dropped this chili poster on Thursday
and in between shooting scenes Murray
has reportedly been spotted at a few of
kelis's concerts I'm always writing I
stay in the studio just sort of creating
the rumor to romance comes more than a
year after Khaleesi's late husband
photographer Mike Mora died of stomach
cancer in March of last year just weeks
before Murray was hit with allegations
of inappropriate behavior behind the
scenes of a project I did something I
thought was funny and it wasn't taken
that way that's Murray reacting to the
controversy the movie titled being
mortal co-star and Keke Palmer was shut
down as of now we're talking and we're
trying to make peace with each other
one year later and there's still been no
word of when cameras might roll again
with or without Murray who also lost his
wife Jennifer Butler in 2021 they were
separated for several years but
reportedly kept in touch until her death
back in the sun's article The Source
claims the couple has found a common
Bond amidst their grief
foreign